you go to rome to have best italian food
or you go to japan to get the best
japanese food
you would come to dubai you get best of
italy you get best of japan you can get
best of india
i would say dubai is the most exciting
city you would find across all the
cuisines
wherever i am in the world food is the
focal point of everything i do
my name is ching and i'm a chef and food
writer my taste journeys have taken me
all over the world in search of great
flavors and new recipes finally it has
brought me to dubai and i can't wait to
explore its rich and varied food scene
one bite at a time
[Music]
growing up in a taiwanese household
meant i ate a lot of spice so i'm
excited to discover what spice
combinations dubai street stores have to
offer with another fellow spice
enthusiast himanshu
hi my name is himanshuseni and i'm a
chef from last 10 years
currently i'm working for two
restaurants present and carnival by
present they're both in dubai and the
third one is in kuwait and the fourth
one is about to open in mumbai
[Music]
but here it is it is more elaborate
there is a place called last exit and
they have 10 15 trucks from waffles to
hot dogs to burgers
street food is one of the key
philosophies at crescent the experience
that you get at the street counter is
something which we want to give to our
diners in a fine line setup my first
initial memory of food my mother along
with us six sisters we used to cook
together in a very big house feeding
almost 50 people a night and that is how
i got the first impression about food is
because that gives everybody a great joy
my parents are really proud of what i've
done so far and i feel very proud the
literal meaning of chart is to lick the
chart is so spicy and tangy that people
usually lick their fingers off
this one is the modern version of the
chart
so they've added corns they have added
potato tomatoes the corn really makes it
interesting yeah it's got so much
texture as well yes
i think we should round off this meal
with a cup of tea perfect let's do it
there's a heart to the cuisine here in
dubai i didn't realize that you could
have such a vast array of choice
[Music]
so this is project chaiwala and they've
got a secret cinema art house experience
here in dubai it's very interesting that
they've bought in professional from
india they've been making teas for years
which is such a basic thing but nobody
has given such emphasis which these guys
have it's really great to see a product
from india being made in a city like
dubai
the dubai street food scene is fast and
very tasty and naturally it's time to
get to see human shoes take on street
food
[Music]
you've seen the traditional version of
the chart at the chart counter but we do
a very modern version of it we're going
to paint this canvas with the chart
ingredients
just splash the chutneys okay
brilliant
[Music]
and then we have this spinach fritters
some crackers and now we will going to
top experience again with some more
chutneys
and now we're going to freeze this in
liquid nitrogen once we freeze it it
becomes very brittle okay and then we
crush it on our chart we mix it gently
and then we supposed to have it
and then beautiful you can get the
texture of the papadi the palak patta
the masala there's so much going on
thank you so much chef
thank you
food is one common language across the
world is how it travels from one country
to another i think my heart is in india
but i feel home here in dubai
i've come to dubai because i want to
really experience dubai culture and for
me the best way to explore any culture
is a hundred percent through food so
there is so much to experience here
dubai really is a place for food